ouais bien reçu
pas beaucoup
à celui qui pêche
il est 4h du matin la brigade du Conseil
supérieur de la pêche effectue une de
ces nombreuses opérations
anti-brasconage il s'agit ici de
civelles au pibal l'Alvin de l'anguille
monsieur
pas de carte de pêche
interdit la pêche au pied des écluses
s'il vous plaît vous avez déjà été
verbalisé
pour le pêcheur et il fait ça 18 cm
de diamètre
après avoir verbalisé le braconnier puis
saisis son matériel de pêche la brigade
trouvera non loin de là une quinzaine de
tamis non réglementaires dissimulé dans
les buissons
nous sommes à quelques kilomètres de
l'estuaire de la Gironde au pied d'une
écluse très fréquentée par les
braconniers malgré la multiplication des
contrôles et de la répression le
braconnage de la civelle sévit de plus
en plus dans la région
[Applaudissements]
la motivation c'est financier c'est pour
ramasser un peu d'argent quoi s'il
commence à attraper deux ou trois kilos
c'est là le rapport de bien intéressant
avec deux ou trois kilos civils il gagne
il peut gagner donc entre
2500 francs et puis et puis 3000 4000
[Musique]
comme chaque année dans l'estuaire de la
Gironde les fortes marées sont propices
à la migration massive de la civelle la
pêche de cet Alvin représente ici bien
plus qu'une tradition ce petit Alvin
surnommé l'or blanc de la Gironde est
attendu avec impatience par les pêcheurs
mais aussi par la communauté
scientifique
nous sommes au séma greffe ou travail
pierre Élie le grand spécialiste de la
civelle en Europe dans ce centre
d'études de l'environnement on cherche à
comprendre comment se déroule le cycle
biologique de ce poisson mystérieux
personne jusqu’à présent n'a pu observer
le comportement de cette espèce à
l'endroit où elle pond ni même suivre en
totalité son étonnante migration
l'anglise est un poisson migrateur donc
qui fait des migrations de très grande
amplitude de plus de 6000 km donc son
aire de ponte c'est la mer des Sargasses
au large de la Floride donc à partir de
cette zone de ponte les petits les
petites larves qu'on appelle êtrecéphale
vont être portées par un grand courant
océanique que tout le monde connaît qui
est le golf stream donc un grand courant
chaud c'est ce courant chaud qui les
amène sur les côtes européennes et plus
particulièrement française
il n'y a pas si longtemps encore ce
petit poisson n’intéressait personne la
civelle c'était le plat du pauvre
certains paysans s'en servaient même
pour nourrir leurs poules et leurs
cochons on a vu des prix flambés en
79-80 les prix au kilo de civelle
étaient de l'ordre de 20 francs 10 kg
pas plus on les a vu passer
très rapidement à 500 francs 10 kg 15 20
ans après et puis on a atteint des
summums dans les dernières années avec
des fruits de l'ordre de 1500 francs les
kilos à 2000 francs les kilos une
flambée des prix qui s'explique
principalement par la demande asiatique
les Chinois et les Japonais sont prêts à
dépenser des fortunes pour ce poisson
devenu très rare sur leur côte pour
Pirelli est urgent de réagir si l'on ne
veut pas que l'anguille européenne
connaissent les mêmes problèmes de
surpêche que sa cousine asiatique c'est
une question d'écologie mais aussi
d'économie qui a 25 000 personnes au
niveau européen qui vivent de cette
espèce là en emploi direct donc c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
important
restez commercial est important mais la
ressource est très bien tout disparaît
si cette ressource disparaît
pour éviter les abus et lutter contre le
braconnage le Conseil supérieur de la
pêche a créé en 1993 la Brigade Mobile
d'Intervention une brigade qui utilise
désormais des méthodes musclées pour
appréhender les braconniers en 6 ans les
garde-pêche n'ont pas chômé sur la seule
année 1998 ils ont effectué plus de 130
interpellations aujourd'hui comme tous
les mois la BMI s'entraîne aux
techniques d'interpellation tout le
monde a au moins une paire de jumelles
par voiture
là ici ce sont des jumelles nocturnes
des jumelles intensification de lumière
les pêcheurs de pivals ont très souvent
une petite source de lumière pour
éclairer l'endroit où ils mettent le
tamis à l'oeil nu vous ne voyez rien dès
que vous prenez les jumelles vous voyez
un halo vert ça devient plus à une
opération commando qui a une opération
de police de la pêche traditionnelle la
pêche des migrateurs c'est une pêche qui
rapporte énormément d'argent et à partir
du moment où il y a de l'argent à partir
de ce moment-là on tombe sur des
personnes qui qui ont quelque chose à
défendre
ce soir la brigade intervient à Bordeaux
même sur les quais de la Garonne c'est
la bonne période pour la pêche à la
civelle la brigade Satan a surprendre de
nombreux braconniers
oui la remontée des décibels sont
toujours plus importantes sur les vives
eaux c'est à dire que sur les marées à
fort coefficient
des coefficients autour de 80 en général
c'est bon
97 c'est à dire que c'est normalement
c'est bon coefficient pour les civils
alors arrivée les caisses sont presque
des airs habitués à jouer à cache-cache
avec la brigade les braconniers ont déjà
disparu
quelques-uns d'entre eux pourtant ont dû
abandonner leur maigre butin sur place
que les gars ont pris ce soir
c'est les deux personnes qu'on a croisé
qui ont qui repartent mais qu'on n'a pas
pris la main dans le sac là vous êtes
repérés sur tous les quais il y a pas de
doute et même peut-être surtout Bordeaux
et même jusqu'à jusqu'à 5000 Médoc à 80
km d'ici la brigade repart bredouille
les braconniers et leurs amis on les
retrouve dans ce bar ici on ne se cache
pas ancien docker ou hérémiste tous
revendique le droit de pêcher la civelle
au même titre que les professionnels
jugés privilégiés comme chaque saison la
tension monte entre pêcheurs de quai et
gare de pêche des fois c'est très chaud
des fois c'est très chaud bon il faut
leur métier nous on est moins cogner les
gendarmes bon ok il y a info et
maintenant il porte le
le pistolet et puis depuis qu'ils ont
une starticle à la ceinture ils ont
changé ils ont changé après ils
arrivaient ils étaient Cannes maintenant
on leur demande nous t'arrives toi du
Vietnam et tu es pas
c'est des fous furieux on casse pas on
n'est pas des leaders on va pas de
drogues on agresse pas les les personnes
âgées on est pécheurs on se contente de
dire pêcheur professionnel ont une
licence donc on le droit de pêcher la
pibale et de la vendre comme ils veulent
et par contre le petit pêcheur qui veut
avoir une licence qui veut payer son
timbre qui veut l'acheter dit non lui il
n'aura pas lui il n'a pas le droit de
pêcher les pêcheurs le ressentent très
mal parce que si on leur disait bon il y
a pas de pival où il ne va plus y en
avoir donc il faudra pêcher uniquement
mettre dans le samedi soir donc jeudi
soir faudra limiter ils accepteraient
ils accepteraient tout cela mais quand
ils s'en vont se promène sur le bord de
la Garonne et que vous voyez ces énormes
bateaux avec les ailes de chaque côté
qui draguent tout ce n'est pas
comparable si vous voulez à ce qui est
appris par les pêcheurs amateurs
alors donc là ils ne comprennent plus
il est maintenant 22h Jean-Paul ducazeau
porte-parole de l'Association des
pêcheurs amateurs de Bordeaux retourne
sur les quais les fédéraux comme on les
surnommie viennent à peine de partir
Jean-Paul ducazeau vient de nouvelles
j'ai dit que j'avais rien à l'allumer
je me suis déjà fait contrôler par les
fédéraux
et puis j'ai recommencé
la voix est à nouveau libre alors on
ressort les tamis on se remet à pêcher
il ne s'agit ici que de petites prises
en une soirée les gains excèdent
rarement quelques centaines de francs
pour ces pêcheurs occasionnels la
civelle c'est juste un moyen de s'en
sortir alors qu'importe les décentrés
pétés de la brigade ce qui compte c'est
de ne pas se faire prendre
Frédéric a 24 ans jeune père de famille
en situation précaire il a rejoint
l'association des pêcheurs de Bordeaux
il y a deux mois
de travail ma femme avec son travail ça
allait très bien mais elle a pas besoin
de ça là je vais me pêcher pour finir
mes fins de mois
et malgré des pêches souvent modestes
Frédéric trouve toujours un acquéreur
j'ai vu un monsieur venir me voir me
dire vous me la vendre et après votre
pêche
moi je veux bien mais à quel prix tu me
dis ben écoutez moi j'ai un restaurant
le monsieur s'est déplacé pour il a un
restaurant il a un restaurant en plein
Bordeaux
alors ben moi j'ai eu sans problème les
restaurateurs pourtant n'achètent que de
très faibles quantités de civelles la
pêche de cet Alvin autorisée ou non
transit la plupart du temps chez les
mariilleurs
nous sommes à Branne sur la Dordogne il
y a une quarantaine de kilomètres de
Bordeaux c'est ici que la société Bor
l’une des plus grosses sociétés
françaises d'export de civelle bien
chercher une partie de sa marchandise
dans les viviers de ce marayer 50 kg de
civelles toutes seront récupérés pour
être expédiés en Chine lessive sont donc
soigneusement triées et sélectionnés
premier choix
50 kg de civelles cela peut représenter
100000 francs là chaque kilo est
justifié par une facture mais vu les
sommes d'argent en jeu la plupart des
marayeurs et des acheteurs sont suspects
aux yeux de la brigade Gaëtan Mabit a
déjà eu affaire à eux moi je passe un
après-midi en tôle pour une histoire
j'ai eu un jugement où j'ai été jugé
coupable alors qu'ils n'ont rien ils
n'ont aucune preuve rien du tout j'étais
même pas là le jour des défaites moi je
dis ne pas avoir été là eux ils disent
m'en avoir reconnu maintenant ils sont
incapables de dire comment ils m'ont
reconnu
j'étais pas là
avant de repartir Gaëtan récupère un bon
de livraison un document qui auprès des
autorités de pêche à valeur de laisser
passer officiel un second livraison et
grâce à ça je le passerai pas mon
après-midi en tôle
retour à Bordeaux ce matin la brigade du
Conseil supérieur de la pêche et la
direction de la répression des fraudes
ont décidé de contrôler plusieurs sites
trois viviers appartenant à des maréeurs
de la région nous allons nous présenter
aux viviers et on va donc voir le
poisson qui est stocké dans les dans les
bassins
le contrôle des factures puisque ils
doivent posséder doivent faire la preuve
de l'origine du poisson qui détiennent
[Musique]
réparti en trois équipes les garde-pêche
s'apprêtent à intervenir simultanément à
l'improviste
police
et la direction
et le poisson
[Musique]
chaque contrôle consiste à vider tous
les bassins afin de vérifier la quantité
de civelles qui s'y trouve les civelles
sont ensuite pesées leurs poids est
comparé avec celui qui apparaît sur les
factures ici tout semble être en règle
donc on a contrôlé le vivier là c'est du
Hart qui qui servait de de surveillance
du site
mais au même moment sur un autre site
lessive ne sont justifiées par aucune
facture
Olivier et chez cochon
d'Aquitaine et non qu'une facture donc
une facture avec une facture chez
clochard
dans ce vivier le contrôle suscite
beaucoup de nervosité notre caméra n'est
pas la bienvenue
ne vous énervez pas
au travail donc on fait un contrôle de
facturation on vous l'a annoncer vous le
savez on fait un contrôle on va peser le
sujet on va voir si
la facturation est conforme à la pesée
mais ne vous énervez pas il ne rentre
pas
aujourd'hui la brigade saisira 60 kg
d'allevin on estime que la pêche
illégale de la civelle représente 50% de
l'ensemble de la pêche que ça correspond
à rien ce connard on saisit
sur les cinq dernières années le Conseil
supérieur de la pêche a évalué le
braconnage à une moyenne de 40 tonnes
par an ce qui correspond selon les cours
à plusieurs dizaines de millions de
francs
c'est pour ça que vous les saisissez il
y a pas de justificatif
on saisit les poissons
réservez les Nantes en Loire-Atlantique
au siège social de la société b.or nous
retrouvons Gaëtan qui cette fois n'a
fait l'objet d'aucun contrôle les
civelles séjourneront ici pendant trois
jours avant leur départ pour la Chine
trois jours c'est le temps minimum qu'il
faut pour vérifier la résistance de ces
petits alevins pas question d'expédier
de la mauvaise marchandise les chinois
sont très exigeants sur la qualité nos
clients en Asie font très attention
justement à la qualité de du poisson ils
vont jusqu'à regarder au microscope la
queue du poisson potentiel est abîmé
les têtes dans les oui voir si on
emplois de micro-organismes parasites
ils épluchent les Cévennes quasiment une
par une
d'ailleurs c'est vendu à la pièce là-bas
et bon il les regarde vraiment de très
très près
ça c'est bien vivant ça fréquille bien
c'est bien translucide c'est du beau
poisson ça on peut l'envoyer sans risque
les yeux fermés rien à craindre
[Musique]
le patron de la société c'est Philippe
Mabille le père de Gaëtan c'est lui qui
s'occupe du commerce international avec
un chiffre d'affaires de 50 millions de
francs par an il est en communication
téléphonique tous les jours avec la
Chine
pour la semaine prochaine mon patron il
a besoin les marchandises courants je
pense qu'on doit pouvoir faire une
expédition autour du 6 autour de 300 3
400 kg très bien
merci bonne soirée merci à demain au
revoir journaliste et qui au téléphone
ça c'est une c'est une interprète qui
travaille pour une société chinoise elle
me donnait les résultats de l'expédition
de la dernière expédition que nous avons
fait et puis bon je faisais une
proposition pour une expédition future
bah nous on travaille on fait disons 80
dire maintenant 99% de notre trafic de
civelle avec la Chine
[Musique]
direction maintenant l'aéroport Charles
de Gaulle l'avion part dans deux heures
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre
conditionné dans des caisses polystyrène
tout spécialement breveté les civils
n'ont à présent que 25 heures maximum
pour arriver en Chine
et il faut savoir que la durée de vie
décibels est limitée donc la chaîne
temps escale plus important le but est
de prendre le moindre risque possible
d'avoir de la mortalité à destination
quand on connaît le coup au kilo de la
marchandise et je pense qu'il est
évident qu'il vaut mieux faire attention
parce que les litiges vont tout de suite
montrer au quoi
depuis le début des années 90 les
expéditions de civelle ont cessé
d'augmenter les transporteurs se sont
adaptés en faisant forte comme on est
actuellement on doit transporter environ
8 à 10 tonnes de 6 volts par semaine ce
qui représente environ
une 10 15 expéditions par semaine
c'est containers sont maintenant prêts à
être embarqués dans une quinzaine de
rappels lessive nagerons dans les
viviers chinois
[Musique]
province de Zen Yang nous sommes à 200
km au nord-ouest de Shanghai dans la
plus grande ferme d'élevage d'anguy du
monde près de 50% des civils françaises
arrivent ici cette ferme le Longchamp
village s'étend sur 150 hectares
le patron des lieux c'est cet homme you
et ping 43 ans symbole du nouveau
capitalisme à la chinoise l'ueping a
construit son empire à l'image du rêve
américain son Longchamp village se
visite comme un parc d'attraction sur le
thème de l'anguille you et Ping a même
recréé la Maison Blanche en grandeur
nature elle lui sert aujourd'hui de
salle de réunion tout simplement
[Musique]
notre entreprise est à la fois la plus
grande de Chine et la plus grande du
monde on a 26000 hectares de bassins 14
fermes dont une aux Etats-Unis
créé en 1987 avec seulement 3000 dollars
l'entreprise affiche aujourd'hui un
chiffre d'affaires annuel de 1 milliards
de dollars 1000 personnes travaillaient
vivre avec leur famille sur ce seul site
le Longchamp groupe produit d'une
moyenne de 30 000 tonnes dans Guy par an
de production considérable dû à un
élevage intensif ici avec un kilo de
civelles on obtient jusqu'à une tonne
d'anguilles des anguilles qui au prix de
gros seront revendus 50 francs kilos
la température de l'eau doit être de 24
degrés très précisément
dans le bâtiment celle de l'air doit
être aussi de 24 degrés pas plus pas
moins
si le taux de réussite d'élevage est le
plus élevé au monde on a à peine 5 à 6%
de perte en Chine l'élevage de
l'anguille est une culture millénaire il
n'y a pas si longtemps encore l’anguy
japonaise constituait leur principale
source d'approvisionnement pour cet
anguille est aujourd'hui en voie de
disparition les Chinois ont donc opté
récemment pour l'espèce européenne une
exportation massive qui si elle n'est
pas maîtrisée pourrait avoir des effets
pervers
si on dénombre jusqu'à 19 sortes dans le
monde l'anguille européenne est
pratiquement la seule que l'on puisse
élever
s'il continue à exporter autant peu de
temps la France connaîtra les mêmes
problèmes de ressources que le Japon
en homme d'affaires très avisé liée
cherchent bien sûr à préserver ses
intérêts aujourd'hui les 120 bassins du
longchain village regorgent dans guide
d'origine française
des envies qui sont élevés et gavés
jusqu'à leur revente celle-ci ont déjà 6
mois
mais à terme comme le crin liau éping le
problème d'approvisionnement risque de
se poser pour les fermes chinoises ce
sont pourtant ces mêmes fermes chinoises
qui à coup de centaines de millions de
francs ont encouragé la pêche intensive
et indirectement le braconnage
après trois années de folie où l'on a vu
les importations de civil passé de 20 à
150 tonnes et les prix se multiplient
par 4 la tendance est à la baisse en
1998 les importations ont déjà chuté de
30%. le Longchamp groupe qui vend la
majeure partie de sa production au Japon
aura bientôt du mal à répondre à la
demande une demande d'autant plus
importante que l'anguille réputé en Asie
pour ses vertus médicinales et
aphrodisiaques à trouver ces dernières
années de nouveaux débouchés commerciaux
comme celui du médicament
dans la boîte verte ce sont des gélules
pour les enfants c'est très bon pour les
enfants Langueux
il y a des protéines de la vitamine A de
la vitamine C du calcium c'est excellent
pour la croissance
la boîte verte c'est donc pour les
enfants la rose pour donner aux dames un
joli teint de peau la bleue pour les
messieurs qui souhaitent renforcer leur
virilité et leur rouge pour permettre
aux personnes âgées de rester jeune plus
longtemps
il faut attirer l'attention des
professionnels français de la pêche sur
le fait qu'ils doivent protéger leur
ressources
il ne pourra bientôt plus y avoir
d'élevage d'anguy en Chine cela risque
d'être une catastrophe aussi bien pour
la France que pour la Chine
la chute des ressources de civelle ce
problème tout le monde en a bien
conscience mais que l'on soit en Chine
ou du côté de l'estuaire de la Gironde
les intérêts sont plus forts que tout
tant qu'il y aura une énorme demande
asiatique la surpêche et les dérapages
en tout genre continueront dans la
région pour l'instant les mesures prises
pour sauvegarder cette espèce reste
inadapté
c'est clair que bon l'anguille est une
espèce menacée ça c'est bon c'est tous
les scientifiques peut-être on peut même
dire au niveau planétaire qui déclare et
qui le reconnaisse et il est évident que
vraiment en cernant mieux le problème de
la commercialisation on couperait cours
à toute une partie de du prélèvement
dans le milieu naturel si ce n'est si ce
n'est pas la totalité du prélèvement
pour moi tous les voyants sont
autoroutes et le simple principe de
précaution à mon sens voudrait que qu'on
arrête de la pêcher tout simplement
aujourd'hui la brigade du Conseil
supérieur de la pêche s'apprête à
remettre à l'eau 60 kg de civelles entre
20098 et avril 1999 pleine période de
pêche pour la civelle les garde-pêche
auront relâché 200 kg une quantité
dérisoire comparée aux dizaines de
tonnes péchés illégalement chaque année
c'est génial
[Musique]